>> There's been a question about what the
most significant innovation
or development are likely to be over the next
decade and I would hazard
that there are two areas that need this innovation
more than any other.
The first is energy.
We aren't nearly sufficient in respect of
clean, sustainable forms of
energy.
You know there's been broad discussions at
Copenhagen, unfortunately
insufficient to reach agreement on how to
bring down the level of CO2
emissions.
But it does lay the basis for innovation in
respect to energy.
I think that are still perceived risks that
aren't quite clear and for
some reason, solar is not quite there.
And for many countries that have developed
a dependence on coal, wind
becomes a very expensive source of energy.
So the big innovation sort, if clean energy
at lower costs that focus
on costs and access to poor people.
And the second has to be in respect to health
care and ensuring that
health care's available.
That pharmaceuticals are available to the
poor.
There's so much more spent on drug treatments
for wealthy people, for
diseases of the wealthy.
And yet diseases that impact on the poor include
HIV and AIDS malaria,
blindness arising from black fly, a not being
properly treated because
there's too little innovation in research
and innovation for drug
therapies.
In respect to finance clearly to ought to
be finance for development,
finance for manufacturing, finance for change
and not as we've seen
over the past 15 years or so, a financial
sector that exists in
[INAUDIBLE].
These are the big issues that will confront
us and as we deal with them
I'm sure that we will make significant improvements
in lifting more and
people people from the ravages of poverty.